what's up everyone perry back here with
another comic-con 2022 interview for
barbarian with star justin long hello
congratulations thank you hello perry
thank you central we were just talking
about last night uh
is this close enough yeah like an ice
cream cone yes that's what we say um
well don't do that well you said like
nice um
yes so fun last night we saw with an
audience i hadn't seen it with an
audience um and it was just a blast and
people were
oh you were there yeah
tell them they were so into it it was it
was definitely like a comic-con crowd
like a very very loud election crowd
yeah i never really had that experience
um i never got to to see a movie like
that with such an amped crowd so it was
it was cool i'm a big genre fan in
general and one of my absolute favorite
things to do is to see a premiere at
comic-con because this audience is just
the perfect fit for
before i get into barbarians
specifically i got a big old broad
career question for you because your
filmography is just filled with a whole
bunch of variety and different types of
things so what would you say is the
biggest difference between your goals
for your work day one when you first
started this industry compared to what
you are driven to do now
wow what a good question pressure's on
yes whoa i'm hung up on these succulents
and the how to hold the microphone so
proud that i stole these succulents did
not steal these succulents oh really
when they look i borrowed them from
another room either way they're here
they're yours and they're succulent uh i
you know i didn't really have very
specific ambitions when i was younger um
i've been thinking a lot about because i
hadn't done a horror movie in a while so
i've been thinking about jeepers
creepers and there's some weird
parallels between this movie and jeepers
creepers i don't want to say anything
about it but um there's uh so anyway and
that i just think about how long ago
that was where i was at that time and um
i'm now thinking about it as you asked
and and i don't think there was any i
think i just always thought i hope i
keep working and
because my mom was an actress when i was
growing up so i knew how
hard just getting jobs as an actor was
so i i had no like
delusions of grandeur about i i want to
be in starring and you know i don't know
i didn't know
i just wanted to keep working because i
love
doing what i do and so
i'm so grateful to keem to get to keep
doing it i get it i say the same thing
on this side of the business all i want
to do is interviews until the day i die
i don't have like an end goal or
anything i just want to keep doing this
keep doing it well that's a great what a
great place to be all right barbarian
now specifically your character i'm just
going to address the elephant in the
room you do not play the most likable
guy in the movie what do you mean um no
i won't get into specifics right now but
when you when you get offered a role
where it is such an unlikable character
what do you look for in the role to make
sure it's creatively fulfilling for you
but it also serves a purpose for the
story right that's a good question yes
um well the first thing is just how how
naturally it's written is is that the
way people talk um does it flow does it
have and
uh it was it had all of that um the
direct the director of writer director
zach is uh has such a great year for
dialogue such a natural here and and so
um i noticed that and and
that the character was as you said um
not very like he's he does really
despicable things and um
and so i i thought well can i can can i
connect with it enough to find
some humanity because
you know i didn't want to play him that
way i didn't want to play him like a bad
guy but um so i had to find a way to
connect and and uh and like you said is
it is there something redeeming about
why he's such a so i i all of those
things were there in spades and um i
just loved this story i loved i just wan
truthfully i would have wanted to do any
part uh um in the movie but it just so
happened to be i i like a great part it
was very great interesting to think like
what if you all swapped roles and made
like another version of it just like i
don't know this is like a fun acting
challenge workshop type thing yeah well
bill could i mean bill has definitely
yeah bill's very equipped and georgina
is such a great actress could do she's
incredible she's incredible and and i
could do anything so um but she's also
she's so good in this because she's such
um she's such an accessible person too
she's such a
kind person and and that really comes
off on on the screen that really is
apparent so you root for her and um and
she does very intelligent things in the
movie it's like
you know people are yelling at her
character because they don't want her to
go back in there and i i've i know that
experience because i've done those
movies where you know people are
outraged by how stupid my character is
and but she actually zach was smart in
crafting um a story that
where the character is actually doing
some like intelligent things um she's
investigating and well yeah whatever
you'll see it she gives that character a
whole lot of heart and it's the heart
that justified a lot of those decisions
that i think could be judged in other
cases it's a much better way of saying
it than my rambling
i believed in her quite a bit yes yeah
so so good whether it's your character
the production process for making this
movie or or anything about like the lore
and the truth of what's going on what is
the biggest burning question you had for
zack when you first signed on and we're
about to jump into it well it's
it's funny you said it because um it was
actually a question that that i kind of
forgot to ask him early on and he only
answered it a couple weeks ago we went
out for drinks
i wanted to know
why exactly he called it barbarian
and the answer was really i won't give
it away obviously but um
uh and i wanted to know where that came
from because zach is such a funny and i
knew him a little bit from uh white his
kids you know and his work his previous
work in comedy
and so he's always been such a
funny
kind of plucky person he's going to love
that i call him plucky but for lack of a
better word he always just seemed kind
of positive and so i wondered where that
dark you know the story is obviously so
dark and i
wondered where that came from but i
didn't know how to ask that
a lot of the genre filmmakers i know are
often like the kindest warmest people in
the world and then they dish out stuff
like this well we're just talking about
sam raimi sam has the most gentle count
you know he's just such a lovely gentle
yeah and and bill i mean it's i loved
getting to work with him and uh because
he that is such a classic performance he
gives in in it uh
and he's just such a lovely person you
know it's it's might be surprising to
people i said to georgina i said i'm
sure you got him because he'd call her
georgie uh and so i said well i'm sure
you got bill to record your outgoing
message and she said well what do you
mean i said you didn't get bill
skarsgard say yeah you you reached g
george's phone um
and she wrote yeah she hadn't done that
so maybe they'll do that now i hope they
press together yes they should makes me
want uh my name to be georgie and then
to meet bill i know
you should all right foreign have to
wrap with you my last question though
and usually i avoid asking this with any
movie or any show but
so when you sit there something as as
like tough and challenging to watch like
this
what do you hope that people take from
this experience where it's not just
about the thrill in the moment but it
gives them a little something to chew on
after the fact as well yes it does i
like that people might it might provoke
some uh some conversation
and um just that just why is it named
what it's not you know there are um
yeah it's a thoughtful thought-provoking
movie hopefully i think um
but to experience it with that that
audience was um
that my only hope was that people
enjoyed it and and they seemed to be
really enjoying it so that was that was
so nice um
and now of course it's out of our hands
but it is funny to see
i i went on um on the trailer on youtube
they posted the trailer on youtube and i
i never do this but i had a moment of
weakness just because i loved the movie
so much i was so curious what people
were saying and and there were so many
theories you know and um and some were
like really inventive like they were
totally wrong but like imaginative and
um and i love that the trailer alone
conjured a lot of uh conversation and
and so i can't wait for people to to
actually see it and yeah it's a good
trailer it's a good trick yeah it's
appropriately cryptic yes appropriately
appropriately cryptic but sells the
right thing totally yes yeah well
hopefully i have to let you go with you
have a busy day thank you so much for
your time and to everybody out there go
look out for barbarians yes
you